Great Mothers, I shall once again
require the aid of your Dark Magick.
The Thread of Destiny demands it.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my full Ahsoka Episode 6 video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references, like some real big,
deep cuts, especially for Nightsisters
in the Star Wars universe.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brain into the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're also doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships.
All you had to do to enter
is be a subscriber.
It is post your favorite moment
from the episode on the video.
there were so many big reveals
in this episode.
This is like another top tier episode
during the season, like next
to the Anakin Skywalker Hayden
Christensen return.
But careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode title
Far Far Away,
which is obviously a reference
to the other Galaxy Peridia.
It's also a reference to the Star Wars
intros to all the movies.
A long time ago,
in a galaxy far, far away.
but in the context of the episode,
Dave Filoni does this really clever
kind of retcon where he makes it
seem like Huyang is the person
telling all the stories of the Star Wars
universe long after everyone has died.
He said it.
He said.
pretty much everybody watching
the episode just went full meme.
The minute that they heard him say that.
But overall, the episode was mostly a
Thrawn episode in a Nightsisters episode.
Like obviously the big thing here
was finding Ezra Bridger,
but it was just like one reveal
on top of like ten big reveals.
the actual intro starts
with a soldier in the purple pod traveling
through hyperspace,
just showing you what it looks like
when they're traveling through hyperspace.
From their perspective,
it looks way more dynamic, too,
like they tuned up the special effects
for hyperspace travel
from a lot of the previous Star Wars
movies and TV shows, even like the newer
Disney Star Wars sequels, hyperspace
travel just looks way crazier now.
just a little while ago at the beginning
of The Mandalorian season three,
we saw grogu you witnessing the Pergolas
while they were traveling
through hyperspace.
It looked way
less cool than it does in this scene here,
like day
four and like, really pumped this up
it looks like the purples are able
to travel through hyperspace
because something in their biology
generates
a special field around their bodies
necessary to enter hyperspace.
like when a regular spaceship enters
hyperspace, it has this little bubble
that it generates around it
the purple, seem
like they can just do that
naturally, like something inside them.
Does that.
other interesting thing
too, is that they can hover in midair
inside a planet's atmosphere
as later in the episode
when you see Theron's camera
doing that,
just like hovering over the tower,
which seems like another big
Lord of the Rings Easter egg.
I'll get to that in a second to normally
it takes an extreme amount of energy
for star destroyers
to hover like that inside
planets atmospheres
because of all the gravitational forces.
so something about the particles biology
just lets them do that just naturally.
Normally in outer space, though, your mass
doesn't actually matter because there's
no actual resistance
exerting any force against you. hoo.
Yang and Ahsoka talk about their history
and the Jedi Order
and how Huyang used to tell history
stories about the history of the Galaxy
to all the Pattons who came across,
including Ahsoka, when she was a Padawan.
they call it part one, Part
two and part three.
Part three would be like everything up
to just before the events of the prequels.
Part one would basically be like
everything
from the Star Wars
version of the Big Bang.
When the Star Wars universe was created up
to the beginning of sentient species,
learning to travel through space.
Part two History of the Galaxy
would probably be something
like the Rise of the Nightsisters
Ancient Empire,
like the Ancient Witch Kingdom of
the Dathmiri Mary, as Balon School calls it,
would seems like a Lord of the Rings
reference
like make another
which King of Ingmar reference.
this is a lot of really crazy
green magic energy in
Lord of the Rings that the Witch King uses
the Nightsisters also use.
They call it magic,
but it's spelled a little bit differently.
that part of history
would just cover the rise of that empire.
Then building all the star maps,
the waypoint hinges that part of history
would probably end with the Knights
sisters being stranded in the main galaxy
or some of the Nightsisters,
because obviously
some of them stayed in that old galaxy.
then the beginning
of the old Republic era.
And then up to part
three would be like everything
from the old republic, the fold
that the creation of the High Republic
era The rise and fall of the ancient
Sith Empire.
Right up until the events of the prequels.
Because remember,
if Ahsoka heard part three
when she was a Padawan
when she first came to the temple,
that would have been before
the events of Phantom Menace.
who is basically teeing up
all this ancient history stories
because we're getting ready to see that
part of the other galaxy pretty basically
where this story came from when he says
a long time ago in a galaxy far, far away.
Obviously probably one of the biggest
references in all of Star Wars.
but he's making
it sound like the history of the main
galaxy started in this older galaxy.
So like the night this was this ancient
which kingdom of the Dathmiri
Mary came to the main universe it.
That was the beginning of history
in the main galaxy, as we think of it. no.
I talked about
how Dave Filoni is making it seem like Hu
Yang is the person reciting
all these stories based in the Star Wars
movie intros, like, Oh, he's the person
that's telling the stories of things
that happened
during the events of these movies.
But when George Lucas wrote
the original movies,
he envisioned that the story came
from the Journal of the Wills,
these creatures here.
And it was the wills
who were recording the
history of the galaxy in retelling things
long after everyone had died.
But I do like the idea that Huyang just
outlives everyone, like, into the vast,
vast future and continues to tell a story
like History of the Galaxy Part four.
And that's everything
that we're seeing unfold right now
in present day A long time ago.
In a galaxy far, far away, a creature
named Grogu who came along in birds,
a brand new Jedi Order,
They talk a little bit about Sabine
and the troubling visions that Ahsoka
had seen her go with Baylin willingly.
But understanding
that she did it to save Ezra.
It was all because of Ezra
even though she and Thrawn
also makes fun of Sabine later in person
because of this
saying that she's basically doomed
the main galaxy to have another Star War
Thrawn was kind of making fun of her
when he was telling that to her, like, Oh,
you've doomed your entire galaxy
just to save your friend.
When, who yanked
starts talking about force visions
being unclear,
like the force can show you things,
but it's always unclear
as to what they actually mean.
That's a reference to both like
Luke Skywalker's force visions
in Anakin Skywalker force Visions.
so in the cave on Dagobah,
Luke saw himself becoming Darth Vader in
all the vision was meant
to show him was it?
Ultimately he would have to make a choice
when he faced Darth Vader in the emperor
and depending on what he chose to do,
he could wind up
becoming the next Darth Vader,
replacing him as the emperor's apprentice.
in an and against force visions.
When he saw PADMÉ, Luke and Leo dying,
it was only a vision of something
that might happen in the future.
But Anna can believe
that it was a certainty
causing him to make the wrong choice
in back the Emperor George R.R.
Martin kind of got into this whole concept
in Game of Thrones
universe when it came to prophecies,
the way it is that prophecies and visions
are always misinterpreted
to disastrous consequences.
Sabine wakes up in her holding
cell in the hyperspace ring,
notices the round doors here.
The kind of reminds me of the prequel
design language a little bit more.
I think it's also meant to be a reference
to a lot of the Nightsisters ancient
design language because of the way
that gold is baked into all their designs.
Then we get a massive info dump
like this is a huge lower info dump
and it is amazing.
Morgan Elsbeth
basically explains the Nightsisters
in a brand new context,
like a whole bunch more lord
than we got during the Clone Wars
or even Star Wars Rebels.
She calls the
actual planet that they arrive on parity.
And it's the ancient home of the Knight
sisters when she calls them the Dathmiri.
Mary, I think the idea is that the ancient
Nightsisters came from this older galaxy
to the new galaxy,
then eventually colonized this planet,
which they named Dathomir.
in at some point, the ones that came to
the new galaxy were stranded.
I don't know how they're going to explain
that.
Like,
why didn't they just use the space wheels
to get back to their original galaxy?
Why did they stay in the main galaxy?
but at some point it seems like the nice
sisters in the main galaxies power wade
because of the way the balance school
and everyone talks about them.
The ancient Witch Kingdom of the Dathmiri
Mary sounds like it was way, way bigger
at one point,
She says the Nightsisters were among
the first people who were able to harness
the power of the Pergolas
and ride them between galaxies.
Probably in the same way
that Ahsoka made it back to this old galaxy
by writing in ships inside their mouths.
But now it makes more sense
Why the Emperor wanted
the Knight
sisters killed off in the main galaxy.
Because they wouldn't serve him in submit
and because their power and abilities
made them a huge threat to him.
they make the nice sisters
seem way, way more powerful than they did
during Clone Wars or during Star Wars.
Rebels like all the stuff
that we knew about them before.
We're just a fraction.
this makes it seem like Dave
Filoni is going to roll
real hard on Nightsisters
Lord during the upcoming Thrawn movie and
we'll talk about that in a second too,
because a big part of the episode reveals
what Thrawn plan is for his upcoming
Star War against the New Republic.
they also revealed that the prettier
planet is where the pearls come to die.
Basically, when they get old enough in
there are just bones
them littered all around the atmosphere.
when they're entering the atmosphere,
you also see them
pass a bunch of huge statues of ancient
knights, sisters.
Those are just the remnants
of the ancient witch kingdom of the Dathmiri.
Mary Not sure how they fell,
what happened to them.
We'll probably learned that either
in the next couple of episodes,
although teased that there's not
enough episodes to completely explain it.
But they might leave
some of that for the Thrawn movies
in upcoming seasons of Ahsoka.
They land on the Nightsisters
version of that same star map henge.
It looks way cleaner like as well.
More maintained
is this giant tower structure
that looks like
it's right out of Lord of the Rings.
Like you could either
call this a version of Mina's Terra,
like it looks a little bit like Gondor,
but it also looks kind of like Baradar
Sauron's Tower in Mordor.
Like you could make a lot of Lord
of the Rings
references in Easter eggs here
between the two series in the movies
like Ahsoka is basically the Gandalf
of the Star Wars universe.
She went from being Ahsoka,
the gray to Ahsoka, the White
like Gandalf the gray to Gandalf the white
with there's resurrection.
there's the one ring of power
in the Lord of the Rings universe.
There's the giant hyperspace
ring in Ahsoka.
so this pretty planet
is kind of like the Star Wars
version of Mordor in that equation.
some of you may have detected
that the lead night sister here,
like the great mother is played
by Claudia Black from Farscape Stargate
She's done a bunch of stuff
Ladies and gentlemen, the beautiful,
the talented Miss Claudia Black like you.
Hello.
I play Officer Aaron, son,
they have revealed too much
about these individual
different Nightsisters.
But they're calling her clone, though.
The other interesting thing here, too,
there's a bunch of dune vibes
coming off of these nice systems.
the way they portray them in live action
Here is a lot like the bene gesserit
in the dune universe
They call them the great mothers
like Reverend Mothers in the bene gesserit
the reason why they all know each other
like Morgan Elsbeth knows the great
mothers, even though they never met
each other in person,
is because they spoke to each other
through the weave that they talk about.
Like the loom.
All these threads
that they keep talking about
is the way that the Nightsisters
perceive the force, that also feels
kind of like a wheel of time Easter egg.
Like when you're talking about describing
the force as a loom like threads.
You talk about strands, patterns
in the weave, so to speak.
That's something
right out of the Wheel of Time series.
Dave Filoni just like pulling out
all the great epic works,
bringing them back in the other
funny Easter egg, too,
is that in real life,
George Lucas was heavily inspired by Dune
with some of the aspects of the Star Wars
universe They also look much more like
traditional Nightsisters.
The way they portrayed them
during the Clone Wars series.
when the series began, they revealed
that Morgan Elsbeth was a nice sister.
A lot of people wondering
why wasn't her skin white?
Why didn't she have the nice sister
tattoos the same way?
part of the idea, I think, is that Thrawn,
who she served in the main galaxy
before Thrawn got exiled
to the other galaxy with Ezra.
The whole idea
is that during the rise of the Empire,
they basically killed off
all the Nightsisters on Dathomir.
But Morgan Elsbeth survived.
Thrawn saved her in basically,
she served him throughout that whole
period
before the original trilogy started.
will probably happen is that after
he saved her in order for her to continue
operating freely within the Empire,
he just told her to make herself
look like a normal person,
like get rid of the tattoos, don't
walk around looking like a nice sister.
they clock's been censored.
She's dangerous because she is Jedi
giving off Jedi energy.
The three devices that they travel with
also look like the exact same designs
that were on the star map.
Confirming the Knights
Sisters really did create
that all technology designed
for traveling between galaxies.
But it was like distantly
ancient knights, sisters
they start this weird subplot
with balance school
kind of getting a little distant
in nostalgic when he starts sensing
this weird power,
quote unquote, this calling to him,
he starts recounting his experiences
during order 66 to 0,
the burning of the Jedi Temple,
likening it
to what's happening in present day
now with the upcoming war
that Thrawn will start.
The important thing though, is that
he says that his grand plan
is to stop that cycle
and something on this planet,
some power will help him do that.
That sounds pretty hardcore.
Like,
how do you stop all war from happening?
Ever? we'll see how that winds up
manifesting.
It could involve something with the world
between worlds, and that's probably
why they included in the early episodes
with all the Incan Skywalker stuff like,
Oh, watch this now, it'll be cool,
but it'll be super important for later.
Bailon also says that the stories
that he heard about Patricia
as a child in the John Temple
were critical to him developing his plan.
But we don't know what those stories are.
So there's like some hidden information
that Dave Filoni hasn't given us yet
that'll probably reveal what
his actual plan is and what that entails.
then Thrawn finally returns
in his chimera star destroyer.
And you know, it's thrived
because it has his symbol underneath it,
just like during Star Wars rebels.
And it still has the damage
from the Pujols.
These are at the end of Star Wars rebels.
now patch with that same gold medal
that it seems like Morgan Elsbeth used
to design the giant hyperspace
ring and spoiler
drop ships like basically nice sister
design language.
love the way they show him
lowering the star destroyer
onto the top of the tower
so that he can literally just walk up
like it's such a boss ass move.
but if we're making Barad der SAR on
Lord of the Rings references here,
he would be the eye of something
like he is Sauron himself.
There's so many things that you could talk
about in the scene of him rolling up to
like you noticed his star destroyers.
Legion has a bunch of red markings
for the nicest shoes on them,
but their armor is all damaged,
dirty, broken
and repaired with that same gold medal.
So the early theory is that they're also
nice sister zombies like Barack was.
there's also this talk about this later
in the episode, too.
Their plan to ferry a bunch of cargo
from the catacombs to the new galaxy,
basically a bunch of dead bodies
that they're going
to turn into Nice sister zombies.
And it looks like Thrawn is depended
heavily on the Knights
sister's powers to do that
and their other force abilities.
the leader commanding
them has a special Knights sister design.
Golden mask in part of his armor
has been repaired with gold medal.
His name is Enoch and he's played by
Wes Cheetham, who was Amos on The Expanse.
Notice
that they give Thrawn his own theme music
and there is a little bit of Star Wars
rebels music
that they mix into the episode too.
Then we see Thrawn roll up in live action
for the first time in his large Mikkelsen
playing the character
who was the voice of Thrawn
during the animated Star Wars Rebels.
There is just another example
of an animated character
doing their character live action,
kind of like Bo-Katan.
there are a lot of characters
in the live action
Star Wars series that are like that now.
Not everybody.
Like there's
some recasting like Ezra Bridger is played
by brand new actor Sabine Wren is played
by a brand new actor.
Obviously Ahsoka was actually
in the animated version and it's
Rosario Dawson in the live action version.
most of you probably remember Lars
Mikkelsen from Sherlock
with Benedict Cumberbatch.
He's only changed Thrawn
just a little bit in his performance
from animation to live action.
He said the way he did
the animated voice just didn't work in
live action
like it was a little too silly.
So he just toned it down a little bit.
but it does sound very similar
to his animated version.
And obviously, a bunch of time has gone by
since the events of rebels.
in I think you could explain him
just weighing a little bit more
because he's got so many more city
miles like it's been a little while,
like he's gone through some crap
in this other galaxy.
So we've got a few extra city miles on him
There are a lot of people
that were making Elon Musk jokes
after the trailers of him dropped.
but I think they tuned him a little bit.
By the time this episode came out
that he actually looks pretty decent,
like what you would expect them to do.
But I think it'll probably get better
by the time we get to that Thrawn movie.
kind of the way that their Luke Skywalker
Deepfake got better from the Mandalorian
Season two to the Book of Boba Fett.
And then the next time we'll see
Luke Skywalker,
like they just keep getting better
with their technology.
I've done a bunch of backstory videos
about Theron's origin, why he's so feared,
even amongst other members of the Empire.
basically the idea is that Anakin
Skywalker bumped into him accidentally
during the events of the Clone Wars Thrawn
learns about the threat of the Empire
and the expanding empire
and wants to save his people.
The kids who live in the unknown regions.
So he agreed to serve the Emperor
in exchange for star maps of the unknown
regions
like map portions of really important
parts of space that the Empire
or the rest of the galaxy didn't have yet.
In exchange, the Emperor would leave
that part of the space
a lot like he wouldn't touch their empire.
So everything that's Ron did.
Like all of his cunning military strategy
devoted to expanding the Empire.
Serving the Empire was really in service
of saving his people, which is Thrawn
is basically meant
to be the most brilliant military
mind in the history of the galaxy.
Like the smartest person alive,
best battle commander you could ever have.
but everything he's done,
like all the terrible stuff that he's
done, has nothing to do with the Emperor.
Like he doesn't care about the Emperor.
He doesn't care about the Empire.
He only wants to save his people, which is
That's why during Star Wars rebels during,
like a lot of his engagements,
like when he would go into battle,
he would threaten
a lot of collateral damage, like all just
burn, kill everyone on the planet
and I don't care about them
because he only cares about the chips.
he doesn't even really care
about his own men that much either.
Like they're just pawns to him,
kind of the way that he doesn't care
about being in school or shooting
Haiti like you might just cut him loose.
Who cares about him?
but everyone in the shadow Council
that we saw in the Mandalorian,
like the Remnant Empire, even though they
all kind of hate each other a little bit,
each one thinks that they're
the best person to lead this next empire.
Like Moff, Gideon wants to lead it
himself.
Pretty much all of them agree
that Thrawn is their best option.
The smartest person in the room
that can help them retake the galaxy.
So when Sabine is yelling at Thrawn,
saying that you wouldn't understand
what it means dooming my galaxy
just to save my friend
like I care about my friend that much.
You just don't understand it.
Thrawn gets pissed off at her, that's why.
Because he did all this stuff
like he served the emperor
just to save his people.
Normally
you don't see him actually getting mad.
Like, that's his whole thing.
Like he's completely unperturbed
by pretty much everything.
But every once in a while
you do get to see him lose his cool.
So there is that.
Yes, Thrawn does care about some people,
but it's just his own people that his
Maybe, maybe we'll see more of them
during the Thrawn movie.
like I said, the cargo transfer.
He talks about his agreement
with the great mothers of the Knights
Sisters
is basically transporting all the dead
bodies of the Knights sister catacombs
that Thrawn will take to the main galaxy.
They'll raise those in those nice sister
zombies will be their brand new army.
merrily theory about the Nightsisters
stranding themselves in the main galaxy on
the planet Dathomir might have something
to do with that green magic energy.
Like maybe that was just
a great source of it in the main galaxy.
And that's why they stayed.
they basically need that energy
to resurrect
all these people, like they need
that special power
is something that you actually find inside
Darth Amir's core.
So it's
kind of this special force type of energy
that only they were able to wield.
it's not something that exists
on every single planet.
there are couple cool scenes of Thrawn
sizing up in school like, Oh,
I remember you, General Balan in school
from the Clone Wars,
because basically all the Jedi
got military ranks during that like
and it can Skywalker Obi-Wan
Kenobi had ranks within the military
when he says that Balan wasn't
the first Jedi to part ways with the order
a long time ago
he's referencing Darth Vader
because Darth Vader in Thrawn
knew each other
when they were both serving
under the Emperor.
Thrawn had an interesting relationship
with Darth Vader, like he wasn't
afraid of Darth Vader in Darth Vader
generally didn't like Thrawn.
He didn't really care about him that much.
Like get him to care about anybody.
both Darth Vader and Thrawn
generally did not care
about the Empire in a grand morality
kind of sense.
They were just tools that they used.
when he says that Sabine will be of great
use to them.
Thrawn
is talking about getting Ezra Bridger
because as he says later,
he hasn't been able to track him down
in all this time.
He thinks he might be.
He could be dead,
but we haven't been able to find him.
so he's hoping that Sabine will find Ezra
and then Balan school
can find them and kill them.
He also kind of throws them on the palate
with this, too.
Like you know what?
After they kill Ezra in Sabine,
then we can also leave them
behind in this galaxy to like,
who cares about those dark Jedi?
Sabine fights the nomads.
Thrawn warned her about just random people
hunting
anyone that comes along for supplies
showing more of a mandalorian fighting
skills.
Also, notice that the rocks around her
have symbols carved into them,
probably serving as road markers
when Thrawn starts
talking about them, a ton of troops
since they've been stranded here.
Thus the need for the knights
sister zombies,
which you see in the caskets
being free from the catacombs.
Like those are all dead
bodies that they'll resurrect
when they get back to the main galaxy.
they're couple of funny moments
that Sabine has with her mouth
coming back to her like a scared puppy.
It acts a little bit, kind of like a lot.
The wolf looks like one, too
In The funny thing too,
is that balance school and Shin hottie
who are writing them later,
they're actually named after wolves
from Norse mythology, I believe.
So they're like wolves riding
wolves, basically.
they meet the crab like aliens
that then take them to their settlement
where Ezra Bridger has been living
with them like a nomadic species.
They just move around from place to place
so that he does not get captured.
and the buck and Jedi that Balan says
Ezra comes from after the fall of the Jedi
Temple is basically Kanan Jarrus
like another Kanan reference.
We saw a picture of him in the previous
episodes Inside the Ghost Ship.
So maybe we'll see Freddie Prinze
Jr in like a bigger live action cameo.
But technically,
he already had to film a scene
so that they could take that picture.
So you've already seen live action.
Freddie Prinze Kanan is just in a picture.
we get our big reunion between
Sabine and Ezra Bridger.
Their energy in live
action is a little bit
like it was together
during Star Wars rebels.
But remember, these are like brand
new actors playing the characters.
So they're kind of trying to recreate
their energy from Star Wars rebels.
Sabine makes a Star Wars rebels reference
and they play a little bit of music from
Star Wars rebels,
looks like he's wearing a chainmail shirt
in the scars on his face
or actually from Star Wars rebels.
what will probably happen,
though, is that she's not bailing
Skull will reach them in episode seven in
they'll have a big fight
and it'll show you some of Ezra's
new force, powers and abilities.
then the great mothers of the Knights
Sisters tell Thrawn about Ahsoka coming in.
He orders Morgan at his best
to basically kill any person
that comes anywhere near the planet.
And like I said,
he doesn't really care
about collateral damage
because he really only cares
about saving his people.
He doesn't mind
killing a whole bunch of other people.
In the process of that, literally,
whatever
it takes to accomplish his goal, it's
kind of like an Ender's Game situation,
like he doesn't mind sacrificing a bunch
a bunch to achieve whatever his goal is.
They make another wheel of time.
Great thread reference.
I guess the great thread
that they're talking about.
The strands are basically the way
that they perceive the force.
They're basically tapping into the force
the same way that Grogu Luke Skywalker,
all the other Jedi, the Sith,
any other force users like The Bender,
but just doing it in a
slightly different way so it gives them
slightly different abilities in powers.
Thrawn saying
that Dathmiri and resurrection are common
misconceptions of the Jedi in the Knights.
This is another reference
to the Knights, Mr.
Zombies, that he plans on raising
when they get back to the main galaxy.
also when he says to the great mothers,
Oh, need your dark magic again.
That magic literally is the thing
that they will that green energy.
he orders information on to
Sophia's history including her homeworld,
her master, who is Anakin Skywalker,
who Thrawn knew as Darth Vader.
They knew each other,
but I don't know if Thrawn knew that. And.
And Skywalker became Darth Vader.
they also covered a lot of
so because early history like her
birth her home planet
during the Tales of the Jedi series.
the other interesting thing
is that in the credits
Sam Witwer is also credited
during additional voices, meaning that
he voiced either some of the droids like
maybe the golden Droid on Morgan
Elizabeth's ship
or some of the background voices.
But when they had the chanting
during the big Stormtrooper Legion scene
saying words
like all over the Ahsoka series,
just like somewhere in the background
where you can't actually see his face.
big things are covering in episode
seven will be that Ezra in Sabine
versus Balan School Shine Hottie
by showing off some of his new powers,
revealing more about villains.
True plans like this mysterious power
that's calling to him on the planet.
Then Ahsoka also
finally making it to the planet plate,
finding some way to make landfall
before they're able to kill her, probably
revealing
more lore behind the Nightsisters
in this ancient witch kingdom of the Dathmiri
Mary, and what was happening
in the galaxy, why they initially came
to the brand new galaxy.
Like why travel between galaxies at all
Early theory is because
of that green magic energy
that they found on the Dathomir planet,
that also probably has something
to do with balance goals, true plans.
there was so many Easter
eggs and references during the episode,
if you spotted any that
I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
going to go down
is probably one of the best episodes
so far.
We'll see if they topped this in the last
two Matsuoka Episode 7 Trailer Video
We'll post tomorrow in my full Episode
7 video
we'll post next week
after they release it.
click here for that
Ahsoka Episode 7 Video.
Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Ahsoka videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe. And this is the way!